downtown Fremont Street upping Security
in the face of several recent violent
incidents recently metal detectors put
in place and now more Metro officers
will call Fremont home a city council
approved a new substation 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough joins us live
after spending the day talking to local
business owners in the area Madison
[Music]
yes as you're about to see the hustle
and bustle of downtown is nothing new as
this is tourist attraction but for many
people who work in the area safety has
always been a concern and now the city
is taking steps to improve it
three months ago Antonio Nunez opened
parlor coffee and cooking in downtown
and while hesitant at first he's pleased
to know that a metro police substation
will soon be right around the corner
later this year when you see the
presence of Metro roaming around you see
people tend to skirt the other way we
really want to see some of the streets
and uh it usually deters people from
vandalism breaking Adventure City
Council Members approving the idea in
Wednesday's meeting with Deputy City
Marshals lvmpd officers and FSE security
all on board working as a team effort
inside the substation city councilwoman
Olivia Diaz pleased with the potential
improvements this will bring to Ward
three and this is a true effort that
we're trying to expedite to bring
more law enforcement operations
collectively together I also love that
it's providing residents and the
adjacency of substation that's closer to
them as well owner of Veggie Nation
Donald lemperly also happy to see this
plan in action hoping that it will help
those who typically avoid downtown feel
more comfortable walking around it makes
me feel good because it's kind of like a
security blanket people know that
they're going to have an extra layer of
help back here you know
and mayor Goodman asking for directional
signs to be put in place to make it
easier to find the substation now this
substation right here will open later
this year reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now